بدات اذربيجان عمليه عسكريه في كندا تحت
عنوان مكافحه الارهاب قالت انها تهدف
لازاله البنيه العسكريه والسياسيه
الارمينيه في الاقليم مؤكده انها ابلغت
قوه حفظ السلام الروسيه بالعمليه من جهتها
وصفت ارمينيا ما قامت به اذربيجانب
العدوان واسع النطاق وطلبت من مجلس الامن
الدولي وقوات حفظ السلام الروسيه العمل
على وقفه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما اسباب عوده التوتر
والعمليات العسكريه بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
في اقليم كاراباخ وما خلفيات النزاع بين
البلدين حول الاقليم ما مدى وجاهت رابط
عوده الاشتباكات المسلحه في كاراباخ
بالسياقات الاقليميه والدوليه وتغير خارطه
التحالفات في اطار الصراع الروسي الغربي
وما افاق نجاح الوساطات لاحتواء التوتر
وخفض التصعيد بين البلدين وما تداعيات
السياسيه والميدانيه المحتمله في حال
استمرت المعارك بين الجانبين
[موسيقى]
مقاعدا قتلى وجرحه صعدت العمليه العسكريه
التي اطلقتها اذربيجان في كاراباخ المخاوف
من انزلاق الاقليم الى جوله جديده من
القتال بين باكو وريفان اللتين تتنازعان
السيطره عليه السلطات الاذربيجانيه قالت
انها مصممه على حل المؤسسات الامنيه
والسياسيه الارمينيه الموجوده في الاقليمة
تحرك بدا على صله بتعقيدات سعى الاتفاق
الثلاثي لحسمها وكذلك بتنظيم ارمينيا
السبت الماضي انتخابات لاختيار رئيس جديد
للاقليم الخطوه الارمينيه لقيت معارضه من
جهات دوليه اهمها الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي وتركيا مواقف سلطه
الضوء على الابعاد الاقليميه والدوليه
لمستجدات الصراع حول كراباخ فلقد اشار
الرئيس الارميني في حديث لا الى موقع
بوليتكو الامريكي الى ان الحرب الدائره في
اوكرانيا غيرت كثيرا في خيارات روسيا
بالمنطقه تصريح يتزامن واج الولايات
المتحده وارمينيا مناورات عسكريه مشتركه
من الحادي عشر الى العشرين من الشهر
الجاري تحت عنوان شريك النسر مناورات قالت
روسيا عبر الكريم انها لن تسهم في جلب
الاستقرار والهدوء الى المنطقه المتوتره
اصلا في تناغم مع موقف الرئاسه
الاذربيجانيه التي قالت انها تامل في ان
لا تستغل ارمينيا تلك المناورات لتصعيد
التوتر الدائر حول اقليم كاريباخ وملفات
اخرى في منطقه القوقاز
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من الدوحه
الدكتور علي بكير استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
في مركز ابن خلدون في جامعه قطر ومن لندن
لورنس
الباحث في برنامج روسيا واوروسيا في
المعهد الملكي للشؤون الدوليه
دكتور علي مره جديده يتصاعد التوتر وتعود
العمليات العسكريه بين ارمينيا
ما هي الدوافع هذه المره مساء الخير لكي
اضيف كريم الساده المشاهدين طبعا التوتر
هو لم يختفي منذ حرب عام 2020 تحرير
الاراضي الاذربيجانيه محتله من قبل
ارمينيا وانما كان يتصاعد بشكل تدريجي الى
انفجر العام الماضي ثم تم تهدئته والان
ينفجر من جديد هناك طبعا اسباب غير مباشره
لهذا الامر وهناك اسباب مباشره الاسباب
مباشره هي اليوم مقتل عدد من المواطنين
اذربيجانيين بال الارضيه في اقليم لجون
كارباخ وتبع ذلك ايضا ارسال عدد من القوات
وزاره الداخليه الى اذربيجانيه الى
المنطقه فتم ايضا قتلهم بلغم ارضي مماثل
وبالتالي قررت اذربيجان اطلاق هذه العمليه
اما السبب طبعا الغير مباشر فهو استمرار
خرق ارمينيا للاتفاق الذي تم الثلاثي الذي
تم عام 2020 بعد حرب التحرير برعايه روسيا
وعدم التزامها بكل الاتفاقيات التي تلته
وبالتالي الابقاء على حاله التوتر
بالاقليم وايضا دور الدول الاقليميه
والدوليه التي يحرض ارمينيا على عدم
التوصل الى اتفاق النهائي للسلام مع
اذربيجان كان عاملا اساسيا باعتقاد لا
سيما دور ايران ودور بعض الدول الاوروبيه
وبالتالي هذه العوامل ابقت حاله التوتر
قائمه تبعها ايضا تحريض ارميني للمواطنين
اذربيجانيه من اصل الارمني داخل اقليم
باعلان الانفصال حيث تم اقامه استفتاء قبل
ايام حول هذا الصدر وقد تم رفضه دوليا
لانه لا يستند الى اي اساس
قانوني وبالتالي ليس هناك حجه حتى لدى
الدول الداعمه لارمينيا لتبرير مثل هذه
العمليه واعطت هذه العمليه طبعا
الضوء الاخضر لسلطات الاذربيجانيه ليشن
هذه العمليه العسكريه الحاليه
لابد من التوقف عندها لاسيما فيما يتعلق
بدور الدول الاقليميه ولكن قبل ذلك دعني
اتوجه للسيد لورنس السيد لورنس يعني ما
جرى اليوم هل يبدو مفاجئا
لا لا يبدو مفاجا اطلاقا برايه في هذه
العمليه اليوم ضد اقليم كاراباخ
كل من يراقبوا المستجدات في المنطقه كان
يتوقع ذلك وهذا يعيدنا الى نهايه حرب 2020
وكيف انتهت انتهت بنصر اذربيجاني لكنه كان
غير مكتملا حيث ان جزءا لا يزال تحت سيطره
ارمينيا وقوه حفظ السلام في 2005 على
اذربيجان اما ان توافق على استمراري عمليه
حفظ السلام او ان تدعو الى انهائها واعتقد
ان عملياتها اليوم محور حول اعطاء مهله
نهائيه من اجل حل المؤسسات التي سيطرت على
المنطقه لعقود والمليشيات الكهربائيه
المحليه ان تسلم سلاحها وبالتالي لا حاجه
الى قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه بعد 25 اذا
هي ما سالت وضع حد لاسس هذا النزاع بحسب
ما تريد اذربيجان اذربيجان تتحدث عن
عمليه لمكافحه الارهاب محدوده النطاق في
ظل الاهداف التي تحدثت عنها او اشرت اليها
هل ستقف العمليه بتقديرك عند هذه الحدود
قد قالت ودعت انها عمليه لمكافحه الارهاب
كما افاد ضيفكم الكريم توفي سته اشخاص
اذربيجانيون
بالغام ارضيه
وكان هناك مشكله بالنسبه للارهاب الارضيه
وعناصر واسباب اخرى مثل الانتخابات التي
قام بها ارمينيا في كاراباخ بحسب التقارير
فان الضربات العسكريه استهدفت بصوره
اساسيه اهدافا عسكريه ولكن هناك ايضا عدد
من الكره التي تم اخلائها اعتقد اننا سوف
نشهد تبعات انسانيه صعبه نتحدث عن سكان
يعانون تسعه اشهر من الحصار ولا سيما منذ
شهر 6 يونيو ليس هناك
وقود لتحرك المركبات ليس هناك ادويه
واعتقد انه سوف نشهد ثمنا انسانيا
صعبا وبالتالي نعم سيكون لذلك تبعات اوسع
سيد علي بكير حدود هذه العمليه خاصه ان
اذربيجان تقول بانها تهدف الى القضاء على
البنيه العسكريه والسياسيه الارمنيه في
كندا
طبعا دعيني اؤكد بالبدايه ان اقليم
ليس اقليما متنازعا عليه وانما وفق
القانون الدولي وقررت الامم المتحده وقرات
مجلس الامن فان هذا الاقليم هو ارض
اذربيجانيه خالصه كانت ارمينيا تحتل لمده
30 عام هذا الاقليم بالاضافه الى اراضي
اخرى توازي حوالي خمس مساحه اذربيجان
الكامله وبالتالي بعد التحرير في عام 2020
حصل هناك اتفاق الثلاثي راعته روسيا وهذا
الاتفاق كان ينص على ضروره استكمال
ارمينيا السحب قواتها المحتله وايضا
الميليشيات التابعه لها وفتح ممرات
بالتوازي بين الاراضي الاذربيجانيه
والارمينيه لكن الجانب الارميني لم ينفذ
كان من المفترض ان ينفذه بالتالي لم يفي
بالتزاماته واليوم تجد طبعا اذربيجان
نفسها امام هذا الوضع هناك اقليم اراضي
تابعه لها لكن لا تزال هناك ميليشيات
التابعه لارمينيا داخله بالاضافه الى
سيده علي بكير تنفي وجود قوات ارمينيه على
اراضي اقليم كنباخ طبعا هي ستنفي لن تقول
انها موجوده لكن اصلا تصريحاتها التي تتهم
اذربيجان بالاعتداء على على ارمينيا هي
بحد ذاته عامل معبر على ان يعني ارمينيا
تدخل نفسها في قضيه ذات طابع داخلي لان
الارض هي ارض اذربيجانيه والعمليه التي
تجريها اذربيجان هي داخل اراضيها وضدها
قوات انفصاليه موجوده على اراضيها فما
الداعي اللي ارمينيا لان تتدخل سواء
سياسيا او عسكريا هذا يضع علامات استفهام
ايضا على
السياق التسويق القضيه من الناحيه
الارمينيه انا باعتقادي انه هذا النزاع لن
يحل ما لم يتم الاعتراف الكامل من قبل
ارمينيا
بسلامه وحده اراضي وسياده اذربيجان وسحب
التشكيلات الارهابيه التي راعتها خلال 30
عام في الاقليم والذي تبعها ايضا تغيير
ديموغرافي حوالي 750 الف اذربيجاني لم
يستطيعوا العوده الى الاقليم بسبب وجود
هذه المليشيات وبسبب ايضا زرع الغام على
كامل المساحه بالاضافه الى استمرار الجانب
الاميني بتهريب الاسلحه من خلال ممر لهشين
الى داخل اقليم نجونو لدعم الحركات الحركه
الانفصاليه والمجموعات التابعه لها
السلطات الاذربيجانيه تقول ان هناك حوالي
عشره الاف فرد يتبعون بالاساس الى القوات
المسلحه الارمينيه موجودون الان في
الاقليم تحت غطاء مختلف وبالتالي على
الجانب الارميني ان يسحب هذه القوات وعلى
التشكيلات غير
النظاميه التابعه لها ايضا ان تسلم
اسلحتها وتستسلم والا الجانب الاذربيجاني
مستمر في هذه العمليه
خاصه ان ارمينيا تقول ان اذربيجان انما
تحاول جرها الى حرب
بغض النظر عن ما يقوله الطرفين ولكن ما
حدود او مدى هذه العمليه امكانيه ان تتوسع
يعني طبعا اذا حصل هناك تصعيد ايضا من قبل
الجانب الارميني وداعميه خاصه
ايران من الممكن العمليه ان تخرج عن
سياقها وان تستجر قوى اقليميه ودوليه كما
تعلمون الجانب الايراني حليف لارمينيا
وايضا روسيا لا تزال تحتفظ بقواعد عسكريه
داخل ارمينيا بالاضافه الى قوات مسلحه
والجانب التركي يدعم اذربيجان بشكل اساسي
خاصه منذ عمليه تحرير في عام 2020
بالاضافه الى موقف الاوروبي الذي يحاول ان
يفضي نوع من التوازن نظريا لكن عمليا هو
دعم خلال ثلاثين عام احتلال ارميني ولا
يريد ان يضغط على ارمينيا باتجاه حل كامل
خلال هذه المرحله
اللاعبون الاقليميون والدوليون يعني
العنصر هنالك الاتحاد الاوروبي كان له
موقف ايضا الجانب الامريكي يتحدث عن ضروره
توقف الاعمال العدائيه على الفور والى
حوار بين باكو وممثلي سكان
كاراباخ تركيا على على لسان الرئيس
اردوغان امام الامم المتحده الجمعيه
العامه قال بان كراباخ ارض
اذربيجانيه ولا يمكن فرض امر واقع جديد
تقييمكم لهذه المواقف الدوليه خاصه موقف
الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي حسبما بدا وكانه
يلوم اذربيجان
كما اشرتم سيدتي انها فعلا
سياقات دوليه متشرمه من جعل لدينا روسيا
التي تحاول ان تقدم نفسها على انها راعي
الامن وحارس اتفاق الهدنه اوقف اطلاق
النار بالاحرى اما تركيا فهي تدعم
اتربعيشان بكل صراحه ايران هي طرف خارجي
تشعر بالتهديد من هذا التحالف الروسيه
تركي ومن ثم لدينا الدول الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده حاول
توسط في هذا النزاع ما شهدناه في سنتين
الاخيرتين هو
على اراضيها نفس الموقف اتخذه رئيس وزاره
الارماني فاشينيان الى درجه ان هذه
المناطق في الدولتين قد ذكرت وبوضوح في
بيانات اوروبيه
انا اعتراف الرئيس الارميني بهذا السياده
لدربه لا ياتي بدون شروط بل هناك مطالب من
نوع من الضمانات والحقوق لامن هذا الشعب
يجب على اذربيجان ان تقدمه وهذا ايضا مال
يطالبه الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده راينا تقدما على مستوى المفاوضات
بين وباكو بين باكو
[موسيقى]
كان لم يحصل اي تقدم
لقد جذبلت اجتماعات وقد حصلت
واوسلطنا الى هنا
يعني لطالما لطالما عرفت روسيا بانها تدعم
ارمينيا الى حد كبير ولكن في الفتره
الاخيره نشهد توترات بين الجانب الارمني
والجانب الروسي ارمينيا تشارك في مناورات
مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وترفض المشاركه في تدريبات
عسكريه مع الجانب الروسي يعني هذه
التغييرات كيف يمكن ان تنعكس على الصراع
بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
علينا ان ندرك ان العلاقه بين روسيا
وارمينيا ومنذ بدايه التسعينيات
كانت تستند الى نوع من الصفقه او
التعاملات ارمينيا تدعم روسيا وروسيا
توفير الامنه والسيطره على ناجورني كهربا
هذه المعادله هذه الصفقه ان صح القول قد
انتهت
وبالتالي ليس مفاجئا ان قياده ديمقراطيه
في ارمينيا تطرح تساؤل تساؤلات حول
العلاقه مع روسيا علي بكير على هذه النقطه
سيد سيد علي يعني ما واجهت ربط ما يجري
الان والاشتباكات التي تجري بالسياقات
الاقليميه والدوليه وتغير خارطه التحالفات
خاصه مع حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا طبعا
بالنسبه الى روسيا هي تحاول منذ عام طبعا
حرب التحرير 2020 باغتت الجميع بما في ذلك
الجانب الروسي وبالتالي لم يكن باستطاعته
التدخل مباشره لتغيير موازين كذلك الامر
بالنسبه الى اللاعب الايراني وكلاهما حليف
لارمينيا وبات عليهما التعامل مع الواقع
الجديد المفروض بعد هذه الحرب روسيا حاولت
الاستفاده من الطرفين حقيقه من من جانب
اذربيجان ومن جانب ارمينيا وايضا الجانب
الاذربيجاني حاول ان بالجزره الى روسيا
لمحاوله تحييدها كي لا تذهب بكامل تقلها
باتجاه ارمينيا فعلى سبيل المثال زاد زاد
من الحجم التبادل التجاري زاد من شراء
الاسلحه الروسيه وزاد من تطبيق العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع روسيا وذلك لمحاوله تخفيف
الثقل العلاقه الارمينيه الروسيه ايضا من
الناحيه الاقليميه كان الجانب الايراني
الاكثر تضررا من حرب عام 2020 وجد نفسه
خارج المعادله تماما حصل هناك اتفاق تركي
روسي
اذربيجان صعدت كلاعب اقليمي وهذا الامر
كان يخالف المصالح الايرانيه وبالتالي
ايران خلال الشهر الماضي بالتحديد
المتابعين يعني
لبروباندا الحرس الثوري كان يحاول رفع
وتيره التوتر مع اذربيجان من خلال مناورات
عسكريه او من خلال اعلاميه وتحريض الجانب
الارميني حقيقه على عدم الذهاب باتجاه
مصالحه شامله مع اذربيجان وشاهدنا هذا
التوتر بالنسبه الى تركيا هي لم تكن ان
تريد ان تتصاعد التوتر على اعتبار انها
استفادت من الحرب الاخيره وتريد ان ترسخ
هذه الاستفاده من خلال اتفاق اقليمي يجمع
اذربيجان وارمينيا وروسيا وتركيا
ومع امكانيه ضم ايران في حال موافقه على
ذلك لكن هذه المعادله لم تتحقق بسبب
الموقف الايراني وايضا بسبب الموقف
الاوروبي والامريكي الذي يرى ان عليه ان
يحفظ مصالحه وبالتالي لا يزال على صله مع
ارمينيا وبالرغم من ان الموقف الارميني لا
مبرر له من الناحيه القانونيه او السياسيه
الا ان موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي كان سلبيا
حقيقه باتجاه اذربيجان الان لكن لا يستطيع
ان يذهب يعني بمعارضه اربيجان الى
اذربيجان الى النهايه لان اوروبا في نهايه
المطاف تحتاج الى الغاز اذربيجاني خاصه
بعد حرب المعطيات التي ذكرت سيد علي بكير
اريد ان اسمع من السيد لورين سيد لورينز
يعني افاق اي محاوله جديده للتسويه
طبعا الامور تبدو صعبه جدا اعتقد ان الوضع
على مستوى العلاقات بين الدول هناك الكثير
من المصاعب
والعوائق
من اجل توصل الاتفاق بالنسبه الى موضوع
الحدود والموضوع الانساني الى ما هنالك
ولكن النتيجه ما نشهده اليوم في كاراباخ
سوف يقود اي اتفاق قد يتم التوصل اليه
هناك مخاوف من الفوضى وانعدام الاستقرار
في ارمينيا
وايضا ان تاتي ميليشيات او فصائل
داعمه لروسيا ان تتدخل ايضا في الوضع
الارميني
اعتقد ان هناك
اذن او مستبعد ان يتم التوصل الى اي تسويه
او الى اي تفاهم في 30 ثانيه سيده علي
باكر هل يمكن ان تنجح الوساطات التي تقوم
بها الاطراف المختلفه انا اعتقد ان الجانب
الادبي جاني منفتح على توصل الى حل سياسي
لكن بشروط التي تم اعلانها قبل قليل ومنها
اعلان الاستسلام وتسليم الاسلحه وسحب
الميليشيات والعناصر الامينيه متواجده في
اقليم ناغورنو كارباخ انا باعتقادي ما لم
تتحقق اي من هذه الشروط الجانب
الاذربيجاني سيتابع العمليه العسكريه التي
يشنها على اراضيه ضد مجموعات انفصاليه ما
لم يتم الضغط عليه من قبل روسيا او
الولايات المتحده مع ان روسيا الان مشغوله
في اوكرانيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ايضا يعني ليس هناك مبررات قانونيه لها
للضغط على اذربيجانب التالي هناك مساحه
اذربيجانيه للتحرك انا باعتقادي سيتم
استثمارها لكن على الجانب الارميني حذرا
لان الجانب الايراني قد يقوم بالتصعيد غير
المباشر وهذا قد يجر ايضا اطراف اقليميه
ودوليه الى المعركه وتخرج على السيطره كما
ذكرت طيب اعود اليك سيد تم التمديد لبدا
دقائق فيما يتعلق بالدور الروسي يعني كيف
يمكن ان يوازن الدور الروسي بين محاولته
للدخول في وساطه وما تقوم بها من ارمينيا
او التوترات التي يشهدها مع ارمينيا
الجانب الروسي يدعو كل الاطراف الى ضبط
النفس يتحدث عن ارمن كاراباخ كيف تقرا هذه
الجمله ارمن كهرباخ هل هي معطى جديد في
الدبلوماسيه او في الحديث الروسي
المقاربه روسيه تاريخيا كان دائما
تاجيل الحديث عن وضع ارمن كهرباء
قدره الضغط الروسيه الاساسيه على دولتين
هي من خلال استمرار النزاع هي اذا لاعب
فاعل في الوضع الراهن
روسيا لديها مصالح اخرى
وهي من خلال
او
معبر عبر ارمينيا وهذا في الماده التاسعه
من اتفاق وقت اطلاق النار في 2020
وبموجه بهذا الاتفاق
الاستخبارات الروسيه هي التي او قوه الامن
الروسيه هي التي تحرس هذا المعبر روسيا
تريد ان تبحث عن سبيل للعوده الى هنا وهذا
على اجندتها
من لندن الباحث في برنامج روسيا واراسيا
في المعهد الملكي لشؤون الدوليه
ونشكر ايضا السيد علي بكير واستاد
العلاقات الدوليه في مركز ابن خلدون في
جامعه قطر
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]